Ist tot vielleicht doch gar nicht unbedingt
tot?
Diese Frage spiegelt eine echte Ur-Angst vieler
Menschen wieder.
Aktuelle Untersuchungen mit Schweine-Hirnen
lassen das vermuten.
Fachleuten aus den USA ist es gelungen, in
den Organe Stunden nach dem Tod der Tiere
zelluläre Funktionen wieder herzustellen.
Clixom Science & Fiction Hier gibt es täglich
faszinierende Science-Videos, abonniert den
Kanal, nur dann verpasst ihr nichts.
Herzlich willkommen!
In vielen Medien wird dieses Forschungsergebnis
aus den USA als “medizinisches Wunder”
gefeiert.
Das renommierte Fachmagazin “Nature” widmet
dem Thema sogar seine Titelseite - “Die
Zeit zurückdrehen” heißt es hier.
Die heiß diskutierten Forschungsergebnisse
erinnern stark an Frankenstein und kommen
von dem Hirnforscher Nenad Sestan von der
Yale School of Medicine.
Sein Team hatte für das Experiment Schweine-Köpfe
aus Schlachthöfen genutzt und das Hirn der
Tiere heraus operiert.
In einer extra dafür entwickelte Perfusionsmaschine
namens “BrainEx” wurden diese sechs Stunden
lang mit einer komplexen Mischung aus Nährstoffen
und künstlichem Blut durchströmt.
Das Ergebnis ist erstaunlich.
Denn die Fachleute wollen Lebenszeichen beobachtet
haben.
Und das, obwohl diese Behandlung ganze vier
Stunden nach dem Tod der Tiere gestartet wurde.
Dazu der Forscher Nenad Sestan: “Das Gehirn
scheint ein bisher unterschätztes Potenzial
zur Wiederherstellung bestimmter molekularer
und zellulärer Aktivitäten zu besitzen.”
Konkret verlangsamte sich der Zelltod der
Nervenzellen und in Einigen konnten demnach
sogar Zeichen von Funktionsfähigkeit nachgewiesen
werden.
Sauerstoffhaushalt und Energiebalance in den
isolierten Gehirnen normalisierten sich.
Und noch mehr: Bei der elektrophysiologischen
Stimulation in Hirnschnitten ließen sich
den Angaben des Forschungsteams zufolge sogar
synaptische Aktivitäten nachweisen.
Dieses Ergebnis erinnert an eine aufsehenerregende
Studie von vor 50 Jahren, in der Gehirne von
Katzen und Affen eine Stunde nach einem Kreislaufstillstand
wiederbelebt werden konnten.
Nach Angaben der beteiligten Fachleute zeige
das aktuelle Experiment, dass dies auch auch
noch nach mehreren Stunden möglich sei.
Doch an dieser Stelle muss eines deutlich
gesagt werden: Eine messbare Funktion des
Gehirn als Ganzes ist keinesfalls nachgewiesen
worden.
Dazu heißt es in der Studie: “Zu keinem
Zeitpunkt haben wir organisierte, umfassende
elektrische Aktivität beobachtet, die auf
Bewusstsein, Wahrnehmung oder andere höhere
Hirnfunktionen hinweisen würden."
Detaillierte Untersuchungen dazu waren im
Vorfeld von der Ethik-Kommission untersagt
worden.
Und so hatten die US-Fachleute die Nervenaktivität
extra durch bestimmte Blocker unterdrückt.
Das Forschungsteam selbst feiert die Ergebnisse
dennoch.
Auch, wenn diese derzeit noch nicht für konkrete
klinische Anwendungen genutzt werden können.
Doch in Zukunft könnte diese Methode eine
bessere Möglichkeit bieten, tote Säugetier-Organe
zu untersuchen.
Langfristig gesehen hoffen die beteiligten
Experten und Expertinnen, dass ähnliche Verfahren
zukünftig auch bei Patienten mit Hirnschäden
- wie beispielsweise nach einem Schlaganfall
- zum Einsatz kommen könnten.
Durch die Präsentation dieses Experiments
in vielen Medien kommen ethische Fragen auf:
Bedeutet tot gar nicht unbedingt tot?
Wann ist ein Gehirn wirklich tot?!
Müssen wir unser Verständnis des Hirntodes
überdenken?!
Fest steht: In Fachkreisen wird die Studie
stark kritisiert.
Und zwar nicht wegen der Methodik, sondern
weil sie unbegründete Diskussionen aufwerfe.
Das sagt zum Beispiel der Vorsitzende des
Deutschen Ethikrates, Peter Dabrock.
Die Präsentation der Studie im Fachmagazin
“Nature sei nicht angebracht und unnötig
“sensationsheischend” Schließlich ginge
es thematisch um das Aufflackern von Lebensspuren
auf zellulärer Eben.
Keinesfalls sei es nun angebracht, die Definition
des Hirntodes in Frage zu stellen oder gar
zu überarbeiten.
Dazu Peter Dabrock: “Das Hirntodkriterium
grundsätzlich in Frage zu stellen, scheint
mir nach gegenwärtigem Kenntnisstand nicht
richtig zu sein.
Denn es zielte ja nie auf die zelluläre,
sondern die funktional-systemische Ebene.”
Und auch andere Fachleute, die nicht an der
Studie beteiligt waren, betonen die strengen
Regelungen in Deutschland bezüglich der Hirntod-Diagnose.
Vor allem bezüglich der Organtransplantation
ist das natürlich eine sehr emotionale Thematik.
Und die Definition des Todes über das Gehirn
ist hier entscheidend.
Fest steht: Eine Entnahme von Organen in Deutschland
darf grundsätzlich erst nach dem Hirntod
stattfinden.
Nervenzellen im Gehirn sterben schon nach
wenigen Minuten ohne Sauerstoffversorgung
ab und entscheidende Hirnfunktionen fallen
irreparabel aus.
Zwei Mediziner müssen VOR einer Organentnahme
übereinstimmend und nach mindestens zwölf
Stunden erneut Ausfallsymptome des Gehirns
diagnostizieren.
Können wir uns Gehirn hacken?
Super Video von Doktor Whatson Anklicken,
und natürlich bis zum Ende anschauen und
Doktor Whatson abonnieren.
Bis dann, bleibt dran!